From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So this is going to be one of those shows where I'm just going to say a few things here and then get out of the way. It's based on a single, kind of a remarkable recording of a thing that happens all over the country, but you never really get to hear it. It's a parole hearing in Illinois-- 13 people in a small room having to decide, should a man be released from prison?
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。这一期节目会比较特别，我只会先说几句，然后把时间留给节目本身。内容基于一段不同寻常的录音，记录的是一件在全国各地都在发生，但你却几乎从未听过的事件。这是一场在伊利诺伊州举行的假释听证会——一间小小的会议室里，13个人必须决定：这个男人应该获释出狱吗？
This fact surprised me. Parole hearings, the system where somebody with a long sentence comes before somebody and gets a chance to get out, that's been abolished in about a third of all the states. Most other states have limited it in various ways. The reasons for that-- people in prison and their advocates said it was really subjective, racially biased, unfair. There was no way to appeal the decisions. They said too few people were being set free.
这个事实让我很吃惊。假释听证会，也就是长刑期犯人在某人面前申诉以获得出狱机会的制度，在大约三分之一的州已经被废除了。大多数其他州则以各种方式对其进行了限制。原因在于——服刑人员及其辩护人认为这太主观、带有种族偏见且不公平。这些决定没有任何上诉途径。他们认为获释的人数太少了。
Conservatives, meanwhile, found it too lenient. They said too many people were being set free. So very few people get out of prison thanks to a parole board hearing determining if it's time for their incarceration to end, though right now, there is a lot of talk about expanding the use of parole boards, making more people eligible. There's a bill in the New York State Assembly, two competing bills in Illinois, and they're in other states, too.
与此同时，保守派则认为这太宽容了。他们说获释的人太多了。因此，很少有人能通过假释委员会决定刑期是否结束而获释。不过，目前关于扩大假释委员会使用范围、让更多人符合假释资格的讨论非常热烈。纽约州议会有一项法案，伊利诺伊州也有两项竞争性法案，其他州也存在类似情况。
Reporter Ben Austen got interested in the question at the heart of all this-- what is actually happening in those parole board hearings? How do they make these monumental decisions? What sways them? What doesn't?
记者本·奥斯汀对这一切核心的问题产生了兴趣：假释听证会里究竟在发生什么？他们是如何做出这些重大决定的？什么会影响他们的判断？什么又不会？
These boards are trying to adjudicate these very squishy, nearly impossible questions, like when is a person rehabilitated? How can you tell? When should a long prison sentence end? This next question is almost too grand to say out loud, but it is in there, too-- what is justice?
这些委员会试图裁决一些非常模糊、近乎不可能的问题，比如：一个人什么时候算改过自新了？你怎么判断？长期的监禁应该在何时结束？下一个问题甚至宏大到难以启齿，但也包含在其中——什么是正义？
All this plays out in this weird backwater of the judicial system that doesn't get a lot of scrutiny. Can you remember the last time you saw a news story-- any news story-- about a parole board hearing? And for all the TV dramas about-- I have to say-- almost every aspect of the criminal justice system in all of its parts, there is none set in a parole board.
这一切都发生在司法系统一个鲜为人知的边缘角落，没有受到多少关注。你还记得上一次看到有关假释听证会的新闻报道是什么时候吗？即使有那么多的电视剧在描写——我不得不说——刑事司法系统的几乎所有方面，却没有任何一部剧是以假释委员会为背景的。
Ben lives in Illinois and spent more than a year going to every parole board hearing there. They happen once a month, each one looking at 5 or 10 cases. And he put together what you're about to hear.
本住在伊利诺伊州，他花了一年多的时间参加了那里每一场假释听证会。听证会每月举行一次，每次审议 5 到 10 个案件。他整理出了你接下来要听到的内容。
The man they're considering for release in this case is 72 years old, been locked up for almost 50 years-- most of his life. The parole board has some information about the case, but definitely not everything you would want. That's part of what makes it so interesting listening to this, hearing how they deal with that.
本案中他们正在考虑释放的男子今年 72 岁，已经被关押了近 50 年——几乎是他的一生。假释委员会掌握了一些关于该案的信息，但肯定不是你想要了解的全部。这也是听这些内容如此有趣的原因之一，你能听到他们是如何处理这些信息缺失的。
This is actually one of the hearings that Ben sat through on his very first day going to these hearings. Basically, he and his producer, Bill Healy, showed up, threw two recorders on the table in the middle of the room, and captured this conversation that you're about to hear.
事实上，这是本第一天去听证会时旁听的案例之一。当时，他和制片人比尔·希利走进房间，把两个录音机往桌子中间一放，就录下了你接下来要听到的这段对话。
And it just stuck with him, this case-- not just the difficulty of the decision that they had to make or all the stuff that they wished they knew but didn't know, but the ruling they came to stuck with him. OK, enough said. Here's Ben Austen.
这个案子深深地印在了他的脑海里——不仅是因为他们必须做出的决定有多么困难，或者他们希望知道却未能了解的那些细节，更是因为他们最终做出的裁决。好了，说得够多了。有请本·奥斯汀。
I'm surprised by how plain the hearing room is, how small. There's barely enough space to fit a wood conference table. And squeezed around it, 13 board members are sitting elbow to elbow. These are people who spend a lot of time together. They're from different parts of the state. And in between the cases, they debate things like who has worse traffic, worse snow.
听证室的简陋和小巧让我感到惊讶。里面几乎放不下一张木制会议桌。13名委员会成员挤在桌边，肩并肩坐着。他们在一起共事很长时间了，来自州内不同的地方。在审理案件的间隙，他们会讨论谁那儿交通更堵，谁那儿雪下得更大。
You guys don't get it like we get it in Peoria.
你们这些人根本不明白我们在皮奥里亚那种感觉。
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 1: I don't know. We're still about 50 miles south.
我不知道。我们还在南边大约50英里远的地方。
Yeah, you don't get it.
没错，你不懂。
They tease each other about being long-winded.
他们互相调侃对方啰嗦。
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 2: Keep it short, Vonetta. Remember that.
长话短说，冯内塔。记住这点。
Oh, look at you tell me to keep it short. Oh, OK.
哟，瞧你居然让我长话短说。行吧，行吧。
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 2: Who said that?
谁说的？
They hunch over laptops and coffee cups and fat accordion files filled with case documents that go back way into the previous century. There's a former public school principal and a high school guidance counselor, former prosecutors, and three retired cops.
他们佝偻着背，对着笔记本电脑和咖啡杯，翻阅着厚厚的、装满跨越上个世纪案件文件的文件夹。这里有前公立学校校长、高中指导顾问、前检察官，还有三名退休警察。
By law, the parole board includes both Democrats and Republicans. They're appointed by the governor, approved by the state senate. And it's a full-time job in Illinois. They're currently paid about $100,000 a year.
根据法律，假释委员会必须同时包含民主党人和共和党人。他们由州长任命，经州参议院批准。在伊利诺伊州，这是一份全职工作。他们目前的年薪约为 10 万美元。
OK, the next case is Mr. Henry Dee. Ms. Martinez is recognized.
好了，下一个案子是亨利·迪先生。马丁内斯女士，请发言。
The hearing starts. The chairman acknowledges Virginia Martinez, one of the board members. She's seated near the head of the table. And she begins to talk about the person they're considering for release.
听证会开始了。主席示意马丁内斯女士，她是委员会成员之一，坐在桌子首席附近。她开始讲述他们正在考虑释放的人的情况。
This is the case of Henry Dee, number C01657. Mr. Dee is currently 72 years of age, having been born on August 24, 1946. I interviewed him at Stateville Correctional Center.
这是亨利·迪的案子，编号 C01657。迪先生现年 72 岁，出生于 1946 年 8 月 24 日。我在斯泰特维尔惩教中心采访了他。
If you look around the small conference room, one person you won't see is Henry Dee, the guy up for parole. He's still in a prison more than 100 miles away. The way these hearings work, one board member travels to the prison and interviews the parole applicant. The pairings are chosen at random. It was Martinez's turn.
如果你环顾这间小会议室，会发现少了一个人，那就是等待假释的亨利·迪。他还被关在 100 多英里外的监狱里。按照这些听证会的工作流程，一名委员会成员会前往监狱采访申请假释的人。配对是随机抽取的。这次轮到了马丁内斯。
Now, she'll walk her colleagues through the details of the case and what she learned in the interview. And she'll give a recommendation for or against Dee's release. The other board members don't have to follow it. Often, they don't. They'll debate, and after that, they'll vote. The whole thing takes less than an hour, and for some cases, way less.
现在，她将向同事们详细介绍案件细节以及她在采访中了解到的情况。然后，她会提出支持或反对迪获释的建议。其他委员不必遵循她的建议，事实上他们经常不这样做。他们会进行辩论，然后投票。整个过程不到一小时，有些案子甚至更快。
Inmate Dee is serving 100 to 200 years for two counts of murder to run consecutively and 20 to 40 years for two counts of robbery. His projected discharge date is June 27, 2162.
罪犯迪因两项谋杀罪被判处 100 至 200 年监禁（连续执行），并因两项抢劫罪被判处 20 到 40 年监禁。他的预计释放日期是 2162 年 6 月 27 日。
Martinez says the release date is 2162. Dee was given up to 200 years. It's what people in prison call "Buck Rogers time," like out of science fiction. Henry Dee-- that's his last name, D-E-E-- first came before the parole board in 1981. People who are rejected get another hearing every one to five years. And Dee has had two dozen hearings since.
马丁内斯说释放日期是 2162 年。迪被判了 200 年。监狱里的人管这叫“巴克·罗杰斯时代”，就像科幻小说一样。亨利·迪——D-E-E——在 1981 年第一次参加假释听证会。被拒绝的人每隔一到五年会有一次新的听证机会。此后迪已经参加过二十多次听证会了。
To make parole, you need a majority of the board's votes. Dee has never even come close. In fact, in all his years of coming up for consideration, only one board member has ever voted for release. That's it-- just one. A big reason-- the severity of the long-ago crime.
要获得假释，需要委员会的多数票。迪甚至从未接近过这个目标。事实上，在他参加审议的这么多年里，只有一名委员投过赞成释放票。仅此而已——就一张。一个重要的原因在于——他多年前犯下的罪行极其严重。
The facts of the case-- in the early morning of August 17, 1971, cab driver Arthur Snyder stopped at his Chicago home after his evening shift. He was accosted by inmate Dee and co-defendant James Sayles, who were armed and forced their way into the Snyders' apartment.
案件事实——1971 年 8 月 17 日清晨，出租车司机亚瑟·斯奈德在结束夜班后回到芝加哥家中。他遭到罪犯迪和共同被告詹姆斯·赛尔斯的袭击，他们持枪闯入了斯奈德夫妇的公寓。
The details-- they're painful to listen to. The crime is brutal. If you're listening with kids, this is a heads-up.
细节听起来令人痛苦。罪行极其残忍。如果你身边有孩子在听，请注意。
Once inside, the offenders hogtied, gagged, and blindfolded Arthur Snyder, leaving him in the kitchen. They then took Edith Snyder into the bedroom, where they bound, gagged, and blindfolded her.
进入室内后，行凶者绑住、堵住并蒙住了亚瑟·斯奈德的眼睛，把他留在厨房里。随后，他们把伊迪丝·斯奈德带进卧室，同样将她捆绑、堵住嘴并蒙住眼睛。
This was a robbery. The men stole some valuables. And then--
这是一起抢劫案。他们偷走了一些贵重物品。然后——
The offenders then beat her to death with a claw hammer, brutally striking her about the face, skull, and body. They then returned to the kitchen, where they beat Arthur Snyder with the same hammer, striking him so hard that the hammer became embedded in his skull.
行凶者随后用一把羊角锤将她活活打死，残酷地打击她的面部、颅骨和身体。他们接着回到厨房，用同一把锤子殴打亚瑟·斯奈德，下手之重，以至于锤子嵌入了他的头骨。
Mr. Snyder was 52 and his wife was 46 at the time of their murders. Before leaving with a number of items taken from the apartment, the offenders turned on the gas jets in the oven and set the mattress on fire where Mrs. Snyder's body was laying.
案发时，斯奈德先生 52 岁，他的妻子 46 岁。在带着从公寓抢来的财物离开之前，行凶者打开了炉灶的煤气阀，并点燃了伊迪丝·斯奈德尸体所在的床垫。
There was evidence of rape, but no charges were brought. They stole Arthur Snyder's car, his taxi, and drove off. All this information is from Dee's original trial. But listening to it in this room, it feels present tense, like these terrible events just happened. You quickly lose sight that this took place in 1971, that a half century has passed.
当时有证据表明存在强奸行为，但并未被起诉。他们偷走了亚瑟·斯奈德的出租车并开车逃跑。所有这些信息都来自迪的初审记录。但在会议室里听着这些，感觉就像现在正在发生，仿佛这些可怕的事件才刚刚过去。你很快就会忘记这是发生在 1971 年的事，已经过去了半个世纪。
The inmate and co-defendant were tried together, found guilty in a jury trial. The verdict was affirmed on appeal.
罪犯和共同被告一起受审，在陪审团审判中被判定有罪。上诉后判决被维持。
In considering release, board members weigh different factors-- public safety, the suffering of victims. One of the most important things they want to hear is that the parole candidate feels remorse, that they're repentant, that in prison, they've changed, which is a big problem for Henry Dee, because he insists he can't say he's sorry-- another reason he's only ever gotten one vote in a couple of dozen parole hearings.
在考虑释放时，委员们会权衡不同的因素——公共安全、受害者的痛苦。他们最想听到的一点是，假释申请人感到悔恨，诚心悔改，在监狱里已经改头换面。这对亨利·迪来说是个大问题，因为他坚称自己无法道歉——这也是他二十多次假释听证会上只拿到过一张赞成票的另一个原因。
The inmate's version is that he states and has always stated that he's innocent, that he's never killed anyone. He states that the blood that was found on his clothing was a minute amount, so small that it could only be tested once. He had tried to get the blood tested again, and they told him that was impossible.
罪犯的说法是，他一直坚称自己是无辜的，他从未杀过任何人。他说衣服上发现的血迹极其微量，少到只能进行一次测试。他曾尝试再次对血迹进行检测，但被告知那是不可能的。
He claims that he had given a palm print that didn't match the bloody print on the hammer and that that evidence has disappeared. He said he was never in the cab. He had gotten a call to meet Sayles and went to Sayles' South Side apartment.
他声称自己提供过手掌印，与锤子上的血手印不符，而那份证据已经消失了。他说他从未上过那辆出租车。他当时接到电话去见赛尔斯，于是去了赛尔斯在南区的公寓。
Sayles is James Sayles, the other person charged with this crime. Dee says he met Sayles at a writers' workshop. They became friends. They volunteered together at a free breakfast program run by the Black Panthers. So that night, Dee says, they were hanging out at Sayles' apartment.
赛尔斯就是詹姆斯·赛尔斯，本案的另一名被告。迪说他是在一个写作研讨会上遇到赛尔斯的。他们成了朋友，一起在黑豹党开设的免费早餐项目做志愿者。所以迪说那天晚上他们只是在赛尔斯的公寓里消磨时间。
Then later, Sayles was walking inmate back to the train. That is when they were arrested.
后来，赛尔斯送他去坐火车，他们就是在那个时候被捕的。
The cab driver and his wife were white and lived on Chicago's North Side. Henry Dee and James Sayles were Black and lived miles away on the city's South Side. The taxi was found later on the South Side, but Dee says he and his friend had nothing to do with it. The police arrested the wrong guys, framed them. He's been saying the same thing for 48 years.
出租车司机夫妇是白人，住在芝加哥北区。亨利·迪和詹姆斯·赛尔斯是黑人，住在数英里外的城市南区。出租车后来在南区被发现，但迪说他和朋友与此毫无关系。警方抓错了人，并陷害了他们。48年来他一直这么说。
At the trial, the inmate, Dee, did testify, and he testified that he and Sayles left Sayles' apartment at about 2:35 AM and were crossing 62nd Street when they had to hurry to avoid a speeding car. Moments later, they were called over to a police car and questioned as to their identity and activities in the area.
在审判中，迪确实作了证，他作证说他和赛尔斯在凌晨 2:35 左右离开了赛尔斯的公寓，在穿过第 62 街时，为了避让一辆超速行驶的车而匆忙闪避。片刻后，他们被警察叫住，询问身份和在该地区的活动。
He testified that the police then took both Sayles and he to a cab parked in Washington Park. They both denied any knowledge of the cab. According to inmate Dee's testimony, they were kicked and beaten by the police. The police then took items out of the cab and threw them on the ground. The police also added whatever the two had in their pockets to the same pile.
他作证说警察随后把他们俩带到停在华盛顿公园的一辆出租车旁。他们都否认对出租车有任何了解。据迪作证，他们被警察踢打。随后，警察从出租车里拿出物品扔在地上。警察还把两人兜里的东西也加到了那一堆里。
OK. So Dee says the police took them to the cab, planted evidence on them, and beat them. The police say they saw them running from the cab. At trial, a doctor undercut Dee's version of events.
好吧。迪的意思是警察把他们带到出租车旁，栽赃嫁祸，还殴打了他们。警察则说看到他们从出租车里跑出来。在审判中，一名医生推翻了迪的叙述。
A doctor testified at trial that the two had not said anything about being beaten and did not observe any recent injuries or bruises on the defendants at the time of their arrest. The inmate states that everyone he has asked to look into the case has said they can't because there is no DNA and everyone involved in the case is dead. He said he could have pled guilty and was offered 20 to 40 years, but he didn't take it because he's innocent. He believes he would have been out by now.
一名医生在审判时作证说，两人并未提及被殴打的情况，且在被捕时并未观察到他们身上有任何近期受伤或淤青。罪犯陈述说，所有他请求调查此案的人都表示无能为力，因为没有 DNA 证据，且所有相关人员都已经去世。他说他本来可以认罪，当时对方给了他 20 到 40 年的量刑建议，但他没有接受，因为他是无辜的。他相信如果接受了，他早就出狱了。
So what to believe after all these years-- Henry Dee's version or the police version? A parole hearing isn't a trial. These 13 people are not here to decide whether Henry Dee is innocent or guilty. Parole was set up to assess everything that's happened since a conviction. But of course, as the board wrestles with accountability and remorse, it's impossible to ignore that question of guilt. What if he never committed the crime? How could he show regret?
那么，时隔多年该相信什么呢——亨利·迪的说法还是警方的说法？假释听证会不是审判。这 13 个人并不是来决定亨利·迪是否有罪的。假释的设立是为了评估定罪后发生的一切。但当然，当委员会在悔罪和责任问题上挣扎时，忽略有罪与否的问题是不可能的。如果他根本没犯下罪行呢？他怎么可能表现出悔意？
Another thing the board is supposed to consider-- the person's behavior in prison. How has he conducted himself there for the past half century? Has he used the time productively? Short answer-- yes, he has. That's where Virginia Martinez goes next. Henry Dee has basically been what they call a model prisoner, with two rather spectacular exceptions. These floored me when I heard them. First one--
委员会还应该考虑的另一件事——此人在狱中的表现。过去半个世纪他在狱中表现如何？他是否虚度光阴？简短的回答是——是的，他没有虚度。马丁内斯女士接下来就要讲这些。亨利·迪基本上就是他们所说的模范囚犯，只有两个非常惊人的例外。当我听到这两个例外时，彻底惊呆了。第一个是——
In 1979, inmate Dee escaped from custody of the Department of Corrections while at the U of I Hospital for kidney tests.
1979 年，迪罪犯在伊利诺伊大学医院进行肾脏检查时，从惩教署的羁押中逃脱了。
That's right. He escaped from prison. This was early in his incarceration.
没错。他从监狱里逃跑了。那是在他刚入狱不久的时候。
He was able to do so by using what looked like a homemade weapon. He stated that he handcuffed the two officers and left the keys and their weapons in the trash can so that when someone went in, they could uncuff them. He was apprehended the next day at a motel with his girlfriend.
他通过使用看起来像是自制武器的东西成功逃脱。他说他给两名警官戴上手铐，并把钥匙和武器留在了垃圾桶里，这样等别人进来时，他们就能自己解开。他第二天就在一家汽车旅馆和女友一起被抓获了。
It's a crazy story. He made a fake gun, like a stage prop, and when he locked up the officers, he was polite. He didn't take their guns. He left them, along with the keys, somewhere easy to find. He wasn't even charged with a crime, though they did punish him by moving him out of the general prison population for a year. It's hard to gauge how this will play with the parole board, especially since, a year later, Henry Dee tried again-- another attempted escape.
这真是个疯狂的故事。他做了一把假枪，就像道具一样，他锁住警察时还很有礼貌。他没拿他们的枪。他把它们和钥匙一起放在了显眼的地方。他甚至没因此被指控新罪名，尽管他们确实通过将他从普通囚犯中隔离了一年作为惩罚。很难判断这在假释委员会看来意味着什么，尤其是在一年后，亨利·迪又尝试了一次——另一次逃跑未遂。
He tried to walk away from MCC, the Metropolitan Corrections Center, while he was downtown in federal court on a civil rights case that I think he and others had filed, which he said he won. So he tried to walk away, and the federal marshals caught and then charged him. So he's got a three-year sentence on that.
他试图从大都会惩教中心 (MCC) 逃走，当时他因为一桩他与他人提起的民事诉讼在市区的联邦法院出庭，据说他赢了那场官司。所以他试图逃走，联邦法警抓住了他并对他提起了诉讼。于是他因此又加了三年刑期。
So he won and lost?
所以他既赢了又输了？
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好吧。
Mm-hmm, yes.
嗯，是的。
A board member makes a joke that Dee won and lost. The man's name is Pete Fisher. He's white, bald, a former police chief from Central Illinois.
一名委员开玩笑说迪既赢了又输了。此人名叫皮特·费舍尔。他是个白人，秃顶，来自伊利诺伊州中部的前警察局长。
During his time on the board, he's voted against parole, like, 200 times, and for release in only a couple of cases. He tells me later, when I interview him, that what always matters most to him is the severity of the crime, no matter how much time has passed or how much someone has accomplished in prison.
在他加入委员会期间，他投过大约 200 次反对假释票，赞成释放的案子只有寥寥几个。他后来在接受我采访时说，无论过去了多久，也无论某人在狱中取得了多大成就，对他而言最重要的是罪行的严重程度。
Virginia Martinez goes on to describe Henry Dee's accomplishments. After those escape attempts in 1979 and 1980, she sees someone doing about as well in prison as anyone could hope.
马丁内斯女士继续描述亨利·迪的成就。在 1979 年和 1980 年的那两次逃跑尝试之后，她看到的是一个人在狱中表现得像任何人能期待的那样好。
In the past 30 years, inmate's overall adjustment has been very positive. He has received only four tickets.
在过去 30 年里，这名囚犯的整体表现非常积极。他只收到过四次违纪记录。
Tickets are disciplinary infractions. And having just four of them over all that time is extraordinary.
记录指的是违纪处罚。能在那么长的时间里只收到四次记录是非常了不起的。
He's currently assigned to the dietary department and has previously worked in correctional industries, receiving certifications for working with sheet metal, which is where I think he made this-- what looked like a gun. He makes file cabinets and other metal furniture. He has also worked in the canning plant. He has never posed a threat to others, except for the use of what looked like this weapon to escape.
他目前被分配在膳食部门，之前曾在惩教工业部门工作，获得了钣金加工认证，我想他那把假枪就是在那做的。他制作文件柜和其他金属家具。他还曾在罐头工厂工作过。除了那次利用看起来像武器的东西逃跑外，他从未对他人构成过威胁。
In 1983, his attitude was described as energetic, friendly, and cooperative. In 1984, inmate's institutional adjustment was described as remarkable. Since 1998, the words "model prisoner" have been used.
1983 年，他的态度被描述为积极、友好且乐于合作。1984 年，该囚犯的狱中改造表现被描述为“非凡”。自 1998 年以来，“模范囚犯”这个词被多次使用。
Because Henry Dee isn't there, he's like a distant character in all the stories swirling about. He's turned into less a person than some abstraction of crime and punishment. But Martinez now gets to say what it was like to sit with him in the present, to talk with him, to get a sense of who he is today, at age 72. He's got a lot of health issues.
因为亨利·迪没到场，他就像所有流传故事中一个遥远的角色。比起一个人，他更多地变成了一种关于罪与罚的抽象概念。但马丁内斯现在能讲讲在现在坐下来与他交流、与他谈话，从而感受到 72 岁的他今天是什么样子。他有很多健康问题。
The inmate is insulin-dependent and also suffers from hypertension, hyperactive thyroid, and abnormal heart rhythm. He recently underwent-- I think it's a second surgery for his heart condition. When I interviewed him, his speech was slow and clear. He was very cooperative and responsive to questions. He had come with his accordion file of information. He keeps all of his information in a file.
这名囚犯患有胰岛素依赖型糖尿病，还患有高血压、甲状腺功能亢进和心律不齐。他最近刚接受了——我想是心脏病的第二次手术。我采访他时，他说话缓慢而清晰。他非常配合，对问题反应敏锐。他带着他的手风琴式文件夹来见我。他保存着所有的信息。
For people Henry Dee's age-- older than 65-- the arrest rate is really low. Statistically, people age out of crime. That's just a fact. But the board still wants to know, if they do release him, that he's got a stable place to live, an income, a plan.
对于亨利·迪这个年龄段的人——65 岁以上——犯罪率真的很低。从统计学上看，人老了就不会再犯罪了。这是个事实。但委员会仍然想知道，如果他们释放他，他是否有稳定的住所、收入和计划。
His parole plan, he has always said that he wants to live with his mother, Ruby, in Chicago. She's got to be in her 90s. He says over 85, but that over 85 has been consistent over the years, so she's got to be 90-something. She requires a caretaker now.
关于假释计划，他一直说他想和母亲鲁比住在芝加哥。她一定 90 多岁了。他说 85 岁以上，但多年来他一直说 85 岁以上，所以她肯定有 90 多岁了。她现在需要人照顾。
He has been saving money for his and her needs and currently has over $11,000. He believes that he can get work in either food service or sheet metal based on his experience and certifications. Additionally, we received a letter at the end of January of an offer from Juan Rivera, a former Stateville inmate who was found to have been wrongfully convicted and won a $20 million civil rights suit based on that wrongful conviction.
他一直为自己和她的需求存钱，目前拥有超过 1.1 万美元。他相信根据自己的经验和证书，他能在餐饮服务或钣金行业找到工作。此外，我们在 1 月底收到了一封来自胡安·里维拉的信，他是一名曾入狱斯泰特维尔的前囚犯，后来被证明是蒙冤入狱，并因那次错判赢得了 2000 万美元的民事诉讼赔偿。
Mr. Rivera states that inmate Dee is, in great part, responsible for the person he is today. He met inmate Dee while he entered Stateville, angry for having been convicted of the rape and murder of an 11-year-old girl, a crime that he did not commit.
里维拉先生称，迪罪犯在很大程度上成就了今天的他。他在进入斯泰特维尔时，因被判强奸和谋杀一名 11 岁女孩而愤怒，但他并未犯下该罪行。
He says inmate Dee taught him that he was not who the legal system portrayed him to be. He is now owner of Legacy Barber College and is a director of Justice for Just Us, a nonprofit providing support for innocent people who are exonerated and released from prison. He offered inmate Dee a place to live in his home, a job with the Barber College, and whatever he needs.
他说迪教导他，他并非法律系统所描述的那种人。他现在是 Legacy 理发学院的老板，也是“为我们争取正义”非营利组织的董事，该组织为被平反和释放的清白者提供支持。他为迪提供了住所、在理发学院的工作，以及他所需要的任何帮助。
Martinez is done presenting the case to her 12 colleagues around the table. The other board members will get a chance to ask questions and deliberate before there's a vote. I can't even tell at this point how Martinez is going to vote. But right now, she says, there are people who sent letters to the board who continue to oppose release. I don't know if it's the victims' family members or who. She doesn't say.
马丁内斯向桌边的 12 位同事陈述完案件了。其他委员将有机会提问并进行审议，然后进行投票。此时我甚至看不出马丁内斯会投什么票。但目前她说，有一些人寄信给委员会，继续反对释放。我不知道是受害者的家人还是谁。她没说。
I would ask that we go into executive session to discuss.
我建议我们进入执行会议进行讨论。
I'll second.
我附议。
OK, we'll go in close. We'll excuse our visitors for a few minutes as we discuss protests.
好的，我们转为闭门会议。我们要请访客回避几分钟，讨论抗议事宜。
The board chairman asks us to pick up our recorders from the table so they can discuss the protests in a closed session.
委员会主席要求我们把录音机从桌子上拿走，以便他们可以闭门讨论抗议信。
And we go in the hallway and wait.
于是我们走到走廊里等待。
Ben Austen. Coming up, the members of the parole board puzzle through everything you just heard, all the pros and cons of whether Henry Dee should go free, and they cast their votes. Stay with us.
本·奥斯汀。稍后，假释委员会成员将梳理你刚才听到的一切，分析亨利·迪是否应该获释的利弊，并进行投票。请继续关注。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "This is the Case of Henry Dee," the story of a single parole hearing for a man who was incarcerated since he was 24 years old. At the time of the hearing, he's 72 years old.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“亨利·迪案件”，讲述了一个从 24 岁起就一直被监禁的男子的假释听证故事。听证会时，他 72 岁。
So here's where we are. The parole board members have heard about the crime. They've heard about how Henry Dee has used his years in prison. Now, they have to discuss and decide, should he be allowed out? Again, here's Ben Austen.
所以现在的进展是：假释委员会的成员们听取了关于犯罪经过的陈述，听取了关于亨利·迪如何利用狱中岁月的报告。现在，他们必须讨论并决定：是否应该允许他出狱？再次有请本·奥斯汀。
The board members take their seats again and settle in. They have to decide whether, after 48 years behind bars, after this terrible crime, that some unquantifiable measure of justice has finally been served. There's Henry Dee's incredible record in prison, too, and also his two escapes.
委员们再次入座。他们必须决定，在 48 年监禁、犯下这起滔天大罪之后，某种无法量化的正义感是否终于得到了满足。还有亨利·迪在狱中令人难以置信的记录，以及他的两次逃跑记录。
And then there's Dee's assertion that he's innocent. It's maybe the biggest hurdle to voting for him. Innocence at this point calls into question the work, in the past, of police, prosecutors, judges, and, also, all those parole boards dating back to the 1980s. All of them would have needed to get it wrong.
当然还有迪坚持自己是无辜的说法。这也许是他获得赞成票的最大障碍。在此时主张无辜，等于质疑警察、检察官、法官，以及追溯到 1980 年代的所有假释委员会的工作。他们所有人都要被证明是错的。
As I mentioned, the co-defendant in this case was paroled in 2004.
正如我提到的，本案的共同被告已于 2004 年获得假释。
The hearing resumes. Virginia Martinez now has to give her recommendation for or against Henry Dee's release from prison. How to decide? Martinez previously worked in nonprofits representing women and children and American Latinos. She was actually one of the first two Latino lawyers ever to be licensed in Illinois, in 1975.
听证会继续。马丁内斯现在必须给出支持或反对亨利·迪获释的建议。如何决定？马丁内斯曾任职于代表妇女、儿童和美国拉丁裔的非营利组织。事实上，她是 1975 年伊利诺伊州首批获得执照的两位拉丁裔律师之一。
As far as how often people on this board vote for release, Martinez is somewhere in the middle. She sometimes talks about her fears of making what she calls a mistake, recommending someone for parole who goes on to commit another crime. And the crime in this case, she told me later, it gave her nightmares. But she now tells her colleagues, she's open to the idea that Henry Dee might be telling the truth and police, prosecutors, judges, and previous parole boards might have gotten it wrong.
就投票支持释放的频率而言，马丁内斯处于中间位置。她有时会谈到对自己犯错的恐惧，即推荐了一个随后又犯罪的人假释。她说这个案子的罪行曾让她做噩梦。但她现在告诉同事，她持开放态度，认为亨利·迪可能说的是实话，而警察、检察官、法官和之前的假释委员会可能都搞错了。
I found it hard to believe that these two men convicted of what is absolutely-- has to be one of the most brutal and barbaric murders that we have, that they never exhibited any violence while incarcerated at Stateville, which you all know about. Even when they lost their appeal, an event that the psychiatrist and counselors predicted would set them off, neither became violent.
我觉得很难相信这两个被判处——绝对是——我们所知最残忍、最野蛮的谋杀罪的人，在斯泰特维尔监狱服刑期间从未表现出任何暴力行为，你们都知道斯泰特维尔的情况。即使在他们上诉失败时——心理医生和咨询师预测这会让他们失控——他们两个都没有表现出暴力。
Inmate Dee did escape and was disciplined. He wasn't charged with the IDOC escape. He did not harm the officers and did not take their weapons. In the federal case, he tried to walk away-- again, no violence. His release would show other inmates that there is hope.
迪确实逃跑过并受到了惩罚。他没有因为伊利诺伊惩教署的逃跑而受到额外指控。他没有伤害警官，也没拿他们的武器。在联邦案件中，他试图逃走——同样没有暴力。释放他将向其他囚犯展示希望。
I believe inmate Dee is ready to reenter society. He has saved money, and he has a financial and other support from Juan Rivera. His institutional record, age, and physical health would be an indicator that he's not likely to re-offend.
我相信迪已经准备好回归社会。他存了钱，也有胡安·里维拉提供的经济和其他支持。他的狱中记录、年龄和生理健康状况表明他不太可能再犯罪。
It's clear-- Martinez is going to vote for release, only Henry Dee's second vote ever. The board members now get to ask questions.
很清楚——马丁内斯将投票支持释放，这是亨利·迪有史以来第二次获得投票支持。委员们现在可以提问了。
Colleagues?
各位同事？
Well, I don't want to get into retrying it, but you've had the case. You've had the file. Is it your belief that he's innocent? Just curious.
我不想重审这个案子，但我看过案卷。你相信他是清白的吗？只是好奇。
I don't know whether he is or he isn't. I think it's possible.
我不知道他是否清白。我认为有可能。
You think it's possible he could be innocent?
你认为他有可能是清白的？
Yes. I mean, he had another case of an excellent record. He says he completely-- Sayles says he completely changed himself. Mr. Dee has completely changed--
是的。我是说，他在狱中有着极其出色的记录。他说他已经完全……赛尔斯说他完全改变了自己。迪先生也完全改变了……
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
--whoever he was--
——无论他曾经是谁——
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 3: Yeah.
没错。
--at the time. I mean, he's now 73 years old. And if part of the goal of the Department of Corrections is to rehabilitate individuals, here is a person who has been rehabilitated.
——在案发时。我是说，他现在 73 岁了。如果惩教署的目标之一是改造个人，那么这里就有一个已经完成了改造的人。
Even if he is guilty and won't admit it, she's saying that whatever we think a long prison sentence is supposed to accomplish, after 48 years, he's done it. They should set him free.
即使他有罪但拒不承认，她也在说，无论我们认为长刑期是为了实现什么目的，经过 48 年，他已经做到了。他们应该放他自由。
This gets at something so basic-- what is the purpose of punishment? It's a question we, as a country, have never really answered. And yet it's here for the board somehow to wrestle with.
这触及了一个非常基本的问题——惩罚的目的是什么？这是一个我们作为一个国家从未真正回答过的问题。但委员会不知何故必须在这里与这个问题搏斗。
Mr. Ruggiero.
鲁杰罗先生。
I just have a couple questions in regard just to the actual innocence claim. The victim, Mr. Snyder, owned the cab, correct?
关于实际无辜的声明，我只有几个问题。受害者，斯奈德先生，拥有那辆出租车，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
And--
然后——
Another board member seated a couple of feet from Martinez, Joseph Ruggiero. He's white, a criminal prosecutor for 30 years. And he starts to grill Martinez about the crime like he's got her on the witness stand.
坐在离马丁内斯几英尺外的另一名委员约瑟夫·鲁杰罗。他是白人，做了 30 年刑事检察官。他开始像盘问证人一样审问马丁内斯关于犯罪细节的问题。
And was Dee, according to the opinion, found in possession of the victim's watch?
根据判决，迪被发现持有受害者的手表，对吧？
No, I think he had certificates or something. But again, Dee says that this stuff was inside the cab.
不，我认为他持有的是证明文件之类的东西。但同样，迪说这些东西都在出租车里。
And wasn't Dee found in possession of an 1893 buffalo head nickel that belonged to the victim?
迪没有被发现持有属于受害者的一枚 1893 年水牛头镍币吗？
There were some things that they found on him and some things that they found on Sayles. That's what they said.
他们身上发现了一些东西，赛尔斯身上也发现了一些东西。他们是这么说的。
And his criminal history, twice earlier that year-- two separate occasions-- he was charged with stealing a car, correct? This would have been the third time he was in a stolen car?
而且他的犯罪记录，那年早些时候两次——两个不同的场合——他被指控偷车，对吧？这将是他第三次在被盗车辆中被发现？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Ruggiero seems like a clear no vote. Next board member with questions-- Donald Shelton, a police officer from downstate, the only Black Republican on the board. And he also wants to revisit the police account of this arrest, which dates back to when Richard Nixon was president.
鲁杰罗看起来明显会投反对票。下一位提问的委员是唐纳德·谢尔顿，一名来自州南部的警察，委员会里唯一的黑人共和党人。他也想重访那起案件的警方陈述，那要追溯到理查德·尼克松担任总统的时候。
In my mind, there's a small vacuum in my understanding how they came to be arrested. The police saw this vehicle driving dark. The car pulled over, and these guys got out of the car. Is that right?
在我的脑海里，对于他们是如何被捕的，我的理解还有一点空白。警方看到这辆车在黑暗中行驶。车停了下来，这些人从车里下来。是这样吗？
Yes.
是的。
Were they arrested in the vicinity of the car? Had they crossed the park? Were they on the other side of town? I don't understand--
他们是在车附近被捕的吗？他们穿过了公园？还是在城市的另一边？我不明白——
He said--
他说——
--how they connected them to the car.
——他们是怎么把这些人与车联系起来的。
I don't know the South Side well enough to know where the parking lot to the swimming pool of-- I think that's where it was. It was near the swimming pool of Washington Park where they parked and then ran.
我对南区不熟，不知道游泳池停车场在哪里——我想大概是在那里。是在华盛顿公园的游泳池附近，他们停下车然后跑了。
So that's on Cottage Grove. Go ahead.
那是在科蒂奇格罗夫大街上。继续说。
That's what I'm just trying to figure out, where they got stopped in relation to the car, because that's kind of--
我只是想弄清楚他们是在哪里与车被拦截的，因为那有点——
It was near-- it was near--
是在附近——是在附近——
Compared to courtrooms, parole hearings can feel like there are no rules. This was one of the reasons many states abolished it. Suddenly, here they are, debating the layout of Washington Park, something they could just look up on their phones.
与法庭相比，假释听证会感觉就像没有规则一样。这也是许多州废除它的原因之一。突然间，他们在这里讨论华盛顿公园的布局，那本来只要在手机上查一下就行。
It's unclear what any of this is getting them. The trial wrapped two generations ago. There's no new evidence. And no one in this room was involved in the case. If this were a retrial, there would at least be witnesses, evidence. But here, it's just circling the same old court documents.
不清楚这些讨论对他们有什么帮助。审判结束于两代人之前。没有新证据。房间里也没有人参与过那个案子。如果这是重审，至少还会有证人和证据。但在这里，只是在翻来覆去讨论同一份老旧的法庭文件。
And even if he is guilty, that's who parole is for, right? People who were found guilty, rightly or wrongly. To decide whether, today, they're ready to rejoin society. But like in so many hearings I've seen, the board members again travel back in time to the original conviction.
即使他真的有罪，这也是假释的目的所在，对吧？那些被判有罪的人，无论判得对错，都是为了决定他们今天是否准备好重新回归社会。但正如我在许多听证会上所见，委员们又回到了对最初定罪的纠结中。
So they were convicted.
所以他们被定罪了。
I get that. That's why we're sitting here.
我知道。这就是为什么我们坐在这里。
So I'm not arguing about-- he says he was innocent.
所以我不是在争论——他说他是无辜的。
Ms. Martinez, you mentioned he claims he's innocent. OK, has that remained consistent over the years?
马丁内斯女士，你提到他声称自己是无辜的。好的，这多年来一直保持一致吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好的。
Absolutely yes.
绝对是的。
And he's had appeals--
而且他上诉过——
He never said anything.
他从来没说过别的。
--and he's had other things, and that's all exhausted. OK. Was there any-- with your interview of him, was there any remorse on his part? Or I guess it's hard to have remorse if you're thinking--
——还有其他事情，都已经竭尽全力了。好的。你采访他的时候，他有没有悔意？或者我猜如果一直认为自己是无辜的，很难有悔意——
Exactly. He just said, I have never killed anybody. I didn't do this. I have never killed anybody.
没错。他只是说：我从未杀过任何人。我没做过。我从未杀过任何人。
Next, visitors are allowed to speak in support of parole or against it. Sometimes, it's relatives of the victims. Their testimony is almost always crushing. I remember one guy. His father had been killed when he was a child. He told me how hard it was to live with that, then to have to come back here every few years and hear the details of the crime again and again.
接下来，访客可以发言支持或反对假释。有时候是受害者的亲属。他们的证词几乎总是令人心碎。我记得有一个人。他的父亲在他童年时被杀。他告诉我带着那样的痛苦生活有多难，然后还要每隔几年回到这里，一遍又一遍地听犯罪细节，那是何等的折磨。
Other visitors include the lawyers for the parole candidates or their family members. But that's not the case today. Relatives of Arthur and Edith Snyder, the couple who was killed, aren't here. And Henry Dee doesn't have any family here either. He doesn't even have a pro bono lawyer.
其他访客包括假释申请人的律师或其家庭成员。但今天的情况并非如此。被杀夫妇亚瑟和伊迪丝·斯奈德的亲属没来。亨利·迪也没有家人到场。他甚至没有公益律师。
Ms. Futorian, are you here to speak for Mr. Dee?
福托里安女士，你是来为迪先生发言的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Please.
请讲。
Only because he doesn't have a lawyer. And I'm not representing him, but--
只是因为他没有律师。我不是代表他，但是——
But you are a lawyer.
但你是一名律师。
The woman who responds is sitting right next to me. Her name's Aviva Futorian. She's in her 80s, and she advocates for parole candidates in Illinois, meeting with them in prison, trying to improve their chances.
回答的那个女人坐在我旁边。她叫阿维娃·福托里安。她 80 多岁了，在伊利诺伊州为假释申请人辩护，去监狱里探望他们，试图增加他们的获释机会。
For years, she attended nearly all of these hearings, writing up notes and sharing them in a newsletter. So the board chairman turns to her and asks, does she have anything that might offer some insight? It turns out, she does.
多年来，她几乎参加了所有这些听证会，写下记录并在简报中分享。于是委员会主席转向她，询问她是否有什么独到的见解？事实证明，她确实有。
A while ago, I was at Stateville, and one of the correctional officers came up to me and said he was a big fan of Henry Dee's. And he knew Henry was claiming he was innocent. And he said, could you talk to him about this? And tell him that if he doesn't admit it, he may never get out.
不久前，我在斯泰特维尔，一名管教人员走过来告诉我，他是亨利·迪的忠实粉丝。他知道亨利声称自己是无辜的。他说，你能和他谈谈吗？告诉他，如果他不承认罪行，他可能永远也出不去。
And that's what I did. I put in a legal call to him, and I told him who I was. And I told him that I thought that there was a good chance he would not get out if he didn't acknowledge his guilt.
我确实这么做了。我给他打了个法律电话，告诉了他我的身份。我告诉他，如果他不承认有罪，他可能很难获释。
And he said, I understand that. I know that. And if it means I have to stay in for the rest of my life, I can't admit to something I didn't do. So that's the only insight I can add to it, was my conversation with him.
他说，我明白。我知道。如果这意味着我必须在监狱里度过余生，我也不能承认我没做过的事。这就是我能提供的唯一见解。
Next, the board chair calls on a state's attorney from the county where the crime occurred. There's someone like this at nearly every hearing I saw. She's there to say why the prosecution still opposes release after 48 years. But she has no connection to the case. I'm nearly certain no one from her office has spoken to Henry Dee in the decades since the trial.
接下来，委员会主席传唤了一名案发郡的州检察官。我在几乎每次听证会上都看到有人这样。她在那儿是为了陈述为什么检方在 48 年后仍反对释放。但她与此案毫无关联。我几乎可以肯定，自审判以来的几十年里，她办公室里没人跟亨利·迪说过话。
So I understand that it may sound like a sympathetic story of somebody who's claiming that they're innocent, but the fact of the matter is, is he stands convicted of this brutal, heinous double homicide. The appellate court reviewed the evidence that was presented and found that the conviction should be affirmed. And that's what happened.
所以我理解这听起来可能是一个关于声称自己无辜者的同情故事，但事实是，他因这起残忍、令人发指的双重谋杀案被判有罪。上诉法院审查了提交的证据，认为定罪应该维持。这就是事实。
This is not the place to talk about actual innocence. I think him denying this would deprecate the seriousness of the offense. Granting him parole would also do that. And I ask that you deny parole.
这里不是讨论实际无辜的地方。我认为他否认罪行会贬低犯罪的严重性。批准他假释同样会造成这种结果。我请求你们拒绝假释。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's almost time for the vote. So far, only one of the 13 board members has said they support release. Another board member speaks up, Sal Diaz. He's seated by the door because he showed up last. He's a former Chicago cop, old-school. He's wearing a tracksuit. He says he knows that in Chicago, there are a lot of documented cases of false arrest.
投票时间快到了。到目前为止，13 名委员中只有一人表示支持释放。另一名委员萨尔·迪亚兹站起来发言。他坐在门口，因为他最后才到。他是一名芝加哥老派警察，穿着运动装。他说他知道在芝加哥，有很多被证实的虚假逮捕案件。
The state's attorney says that he was convicted, but we all know some convictions, even though they were on the appellate level, are bogus, OK? We understand that. And I'm a former policeman. I've seen that over and over again. Bad arrests. But he had the victim's property on him.
州检察官说他被定罪了，但我们都知道，有些定罪即使是在上诉层面，也是造假的，对吧？我们明白这一点。我是一名前警察。我反复看到过这种情况。糟糕的逮捕。但他当时持有受害者的财产。
That's what the police say.
那是警察说的。
That's what he said.
那是他说过的。
But even some of that property is property that would have been in the cab--
但即使是那些财产，有些也本来就在出租车里——
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 4: In the cab.
在出租车里。
--not--
——而不是——
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 5: Right.
没错。
--on the victim.
——在受害者身上。
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 5: On the victim.
在受害者身上。
So--
所以——
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 5: OK.
好的。
So there's some--
所以有——
And if the police--
而且如果警察——
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 5: Yeah, and if they dumped it all on the floor, all out.
是的，如果他们把东西全都倒在地板上。
Simply because the police chase people doesn't mean that the police are lying when they catch them. You know, it can be 50-50.
仅仅因为警察追逐人们并不意味着警察在抓住他们时就是在撒谎。你知道，这可能是 50 对 50。
50-50? Those seem like terrible odds the police might be lying. Still, Diaz says he'd be more ready to vote for parole if Henry Dee just hadn't said he was innocent.
50 对 50？这听起来警察可能在撒谎的概率高得可怕。不过，迪亚兹说，如果亨利·迪没说自己是无辜的，他会更愿意投假释票。
I wish, for me, he would have said, no comment, as opposed to, I'm innocent. And that would have made me feel a little more comfortable.
如果他说“无可奉告”，而不是“我是无辜的”，我会感觉更舒服一点。
At the same time, he's done a lot of good work. And Martinez has pled his case very well. And sometimes, I think we have to just say, hey, there may be some doubts here. I like the guy. He's impressed me. But he needs to go home. And I understand that. And that's all I'm going to say.
与此同时，他确实做了很多好事。马丁内斯为他辩护得很出色。有时我认为我们必须承认，这里可能确实存在疑点。我挺喜欢这个家伙的。他给我留下了深刻印象。但他需要回家。我就说这么多。
At first, Diaz seemed like a definite no. Now, I'm not so sure. The chairman, Craig Findley, has been on the board longer than anyone else. He's a former state legislator, a moderate Republican. He says he's also troubled that Henry Dee never accepted responsibility for the crime.
起初，迪亚兹看起来肯定投反对票。现在，我不确定了。主席克雷格·芬德利在委员会待的时间比任何人都长。他是一位前州议员，温和派共和党人。他说他也很困扰亨利·迪从未接受罪行。
The other man arrested with Henry Dee eventually did. Initially, James Sayles also said he was innocent. Their stories lined up. Then after years in prison, Sayles admitted he was guilty, that they did the crime. And after that, he got paroled.
与亨利·迪一起被捕的另一个人最终承认了。起初，詹姆斯·赛尔斯也说自己是无辜的。他们的故事完全一致。后来在狱中多年后，赛尔斯承认他有罪，承认他们犯下了罪行。此后，他获得了假释。
Voting to parole Mr. Sayles was probably the most difficult vote I ever cast. It was probably in 2005 or 2006.
投票给赛尔斯假释大概是我投过的最困难的票。大概是在 2005 或 2006 年。
Yeah, it was '05, but--
是的，是在 05 年，但是——
Yeah, that was probably my most difficult vote at the time because of the gruesome nature of the crime. Ms. Futorian, correct me if I'm wrong, but it seems to me Mr. Sayles not only admitted his own guilt, but indicated that Mr. Dee was his co-defendant. Much as I would like to support Mr. Dee, I'm troubled to consider paroling him.
是的，那可能是我当时最困难的投票，因为罪行性质极其残忍。福托里安女士，如果我错了请纠正我，但据我所知，赛尔斯先生不仅承认了自己的罪行，还指出迪先生是他的共同被告。尽管我希望能支持迪先生，但我对考虑假释他感到困扰。
The chairman looks like another no vote for parole. There's often a randomness to these hearings. Sometimes, the outcome seems like it's 100% certain, and then a board member will offer a stray comment, and it swings the momentum in the opposite direction.
主席看起来像是投假释反对票的另一个人。这些听证会往往带有随意性。有时候结果看起来是百分之百确定的，然后一名委员发表了一句随意的评论， momentum 就会向相反方向偏移。
There's a board member who's barely spoken today, Lisa Daniels. She's Black, in her 50s. Tattooed on one of her forearms are the words "I am forgiveness."
有一名委员今天几乎没说话，丽莎·丹尼尔斯。她是一位 50 多岁的黑人女性。她的前臂上纹着“我是宽恕”。
At these hearings, she'll occasionally bring up how her own son was murdered. He was trying to rob another young man in a drug deal when he was shot. She'll mention this to stress that her son shouldn't be summed up by one terrible moment, that nobody should. And right now, she says she wants to share a theory.
在这些听证会上，她偶尔会提到她自己的儿子是如何被谋杀的。他在一场毒品交易中试图抢劫另一名年轻人时被枪杀。她会提到这一点来强调，她的儿子不应该被那一个可怕的时刻所定义，任何人都不是。而此刻，她说她想分享一个理论。
Can I ask something or offer something for consideration? Ms. Futorian mentioned earlier that Mr. Dee was told that if he did not acknowledge--
我能问个问题或提供一点考量吗？福托里安女士刚才提到，迪先生被告知如果他不承认——
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 6: I was just going to say that.
我正要说这个。
--committing the crime, that he would never be paroled. Maybe we want to take into consideration that Mr. Sayles took that advice, that Mr. Sayles was given that same advice and that he took it.
——犯下罪行，他就永远不会获得假释。也许我们想考虑到，赛尔斯先生采纳了那个建议，赛尔斯先生也收到了同样的建议，并且他接受了。
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 7: Yeah.
是的。
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 6: That's exactly what I was going to say.
这正是我想说的。
That's a rational assumption to make.
这是一个合理的假设。
It's like something in the room shifts. I see a few heads nodding. People are agreeing.
房间里的气氛似乎变了。我看到几个头在点动。人们表示赞同。
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 6: We don't know. We'll never know.
我们不知道。我们永远不会知道。
I mean, we don't know, and we'll never know. But--
我是说，我们不知道，我们永远不会知道。但是——
(SUBJECT) BOARD MEMBER 7: Right.
没错。
--I would like to offer it as a consideration.
——我想把它作为一个考量提出来。
I asked him that-- Sayles. He said no. He said no. We brought it up. But he didn't point a finger at that.
我问过他——赛尔斯。他说没有。他说没有。我们提过。但他没有指控任何人。
And just one more thing. The reason I brought that up is because what I'm not hearing-- and maybe Ms. Martinez can speak to that-- is that typically, when someone changes, completely changes their behavior and their mindset, there's a point.
还有一件事。我之所以提出这一点，是因为我没听到的是——也许马丁内斯女士能说说——通常，当一个人改变，彻底改变了他们的行为和思维方式，会有某个转折点。
There's a religious conversion. There's some sort of eye-opening, life-altering event that changes a person. And I'm not hearing that that took place for either one of these gentlemen throughout their period of incarceration.
会有某种宗教信仰转换。会有某种醍醐灌顶、改变人生的事件发生。我没听到这两位先生在服刑期间发生了这种事。
And so my mind is wondering, how is it that people-- how is it that these two men could have committed such a violent, violent, heinous crime, but then moved on to live a life of peace or such a peaceful existence without some point of turn?
所以我很纳闷，这些人——这两个人怎么会犯下如此暴力、如此令人发指的罪行，然后又过上和平的生活，或者说这种和平的存在，却没有任何转折点？
That's my question, too. How could these two individuals who, at Stateville, have such an incredible record, and not only for themselves, but for Dee to be a mediator-- which the counselors tell us, too. They mediate the fights between inmates, as well as between the staff and the inmates. How could somebody who-- these were horrible, horrible murders.
这也是我的问题。这两个人在斯泰特维尔有着如此不可思议的记录，不仅为了他们自己，迪还是个调解员——咨询师也告诉我们这一点。他们调解囚犯之间的冲突，也调解员工和囚犯之间的冲突。怎么可能有人——这些是极其可怕的谋杀。
Yeah, we got-- yeah.
是的，我们有——是的。
I mean, the pictures are there. They're horrible. But how could that-- and especially when even the psychiatrist said, oh, yeah, but if they don't win their appeal, they're going to go off. No, they lost their appeal, and they didn't. They didn't go crazy. They didn't cause any problems in the institution.
我是说，照片都在那里。它们很可怕。但怎么可能——特别是当连精神科医生都说，哦，是的，但如果他们不赢得上诉，他们就会失控。不，他们上诉失败了，他们也没有。他们没有变疯。他们在监狱里没有引起任何问题。
There really is no way to prove any of this, that someone who commits a terrible act of violence couldn't go on and live a life of peace, other than a feeling.
真的无法证明这一切，证明一个犯下可怕暴力行为的人不能继续过上和平的生活，这只能靠感觉。
Has he had prior counsel?
他有之前的辩护律师吗？
Not for us, I don't think. He had the same counsel with Sayles for the appeal, but after that, I don't think he's had an attorney.
我不认为是我们这里的。他在上诉时和赛尔斯有同样的辩护律师，但那之后，我不认为他还有过律师。
I don't think he's ever been represented before, but he's been eligible for parole--
我不认为他之前有过代理律师，但他一直有资格假释——
19--
19——
--previously--
——以前——
--81.
——81年。
--for a very long time.
——很长一段时间了。
1981, he came before us for the first time. In all that time, he's gotten one vote. And there was, actually, also a statement in one of those decisions about, he needed a little more time. You have it now.
1981 年，他第一次出现在我们面前。在那段时间里，他只获得过一张赞成票。事实上，其中一个决定中也有一份声明说，他还需要一点时间。你现在有了。
But it was '83-- it might have been later-- that the board said he needed a little more time. He's had it. He's had 46 years. I believe that he's been rehabilitated. And I believe that he presents an acceptable risk. And so I move that we--
但那是 83 年——也许更晚一些——委员会说他还需要一点时间。他已经有那个时间了。他已经服刑 46 年了。我相信他已经完成了改造。我相信他构成可接受的风险。所以我动议我们——
Overruled. Did you say--
驳回。你是说——
Oh, first, is there a second of the motion?
噢，首先，有人附议动议吗？
Second.
附议。
Ms. Harris. Ms. Perkins.
哈里斯女士。珀金斯女士。
Did you say he just had four tickets in--
你说他只收到四次违纪记录在——
30 years.
30年里。
Four tickets in 30 years.
30年里四次违纪记录。
At Stateville. At Stateville. I keep thinking about that.
在斯泰特维尔。在斯泰特维尔。我一直想着这件事。
Easy place to get tickets.
那是很容易收到违纪记录的地方。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
And then after this discussion that zigged and zagged, suddenly, the conversation's over. It's finally time. The board members will cast their votes. Henry Dee needs eight yeses to get parole, a majority of the 14-member board. This is even harder today because one of the board members is absent. He still needs eight votes, though. Those are the rules.
经过这次七嘴八舌的讨论，谈话突然结束了。终于到了。委员们将投出他们的票。亨利·迪需要八张赞成票才能获得假释，即 14 名成员委员会的多数。今天因为有一名委员缺席，投票变得更加困难。但他仍然需要八张票。这就是规定。
All right. Any further discussion? Hearing none, the motion is to grant an aye, yes vote as to grant parole to Mr. Henry Dee. Please take the roll.
好了。还有进一步讨论吗？没听到的话，动议是投票赞成给予亨利·迪先生假释。请点名。
Ms. Martinez?
马丁内斯女士？
Yes.
赞成。
Mr. Norton?
诺顿先生？
No.
反对。
Ms. Perkins?
珀金斯女士？
Yes.
赞成。
Mr. Ruggiero?
鲁杰罗先生？
No.
反对。
Mr. Shelton?
谢尔顿先生？
Yes.
赞成。
Mr. Tuby?
图比先生？
No.
反对。
Ms. Wilson?
威尔逊女士？
Yes.
赞成。
Ms. Daniels?
丹尼尔斯女士？
Yes.
赞成。
Mr. Diaz?
迪亚兹先生？
I think he's dirty, but I'm going to vote for him.
我认为他很肮脏，但我还是投赞成票。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Sal Diaz, the Chicago cop, certainly not soft on crime, says he's dirty. He still thinks Henry Dee is guilty. But, he shrugs, he'll vote for him anyway.
芝加哥警察萨尔·迪亚兹，绝不是对犯罪心慈手软的人，说他很肮脏。他仍然认为亨利·迪是有罪的。但，他耸耸肩，他还是会投票支持他。
Mr. Dunn?
邓恩先生？
Yes.
赞成。
Is that a yes?
那是赞成票吗？
Ms. Harris?
哈里斯女士？
Yes.
赞成。
[AUDIBLE GASP]
[倒吸凉气的声音]
You can hear a gasp from someone in the room because that was the eighth vote.
你可以听到房间里有人倒吸一口冷气，因为那是第八张票。
Chairman Findley?
芬德利主席？
I'll go with Sal. Yes. Dirty as the day is long.
我跟萨尔投一样的票。赞成。尽管他肮脏透顶。
[? (SUBJECT) DONALD SHELTON: ?] Thank you. He made it.
[唐纳德·谢尔顿：？] 谢谢。他成功了。
But please read the result. He did receive eight votes. Is that correct?
但请宣读结果。他确实获得了八张票。正确吗？
Nine.
九张。
Nine votes.
九张票。
The board order parole will be granted-- do we need 90 days, Samantha?
委员会下令假释获准——我们需要 90 天的时间吗，萨曼莎？
Yes.
是的。
90 days from today, the--
自今天起 90 天后——
After 48 years of incarceration, Henry Dee was going free. The whole thing took less than an hour. Of the seven cases the board considers today, this is the only one granted release, and I can't stop thinking about it. It's all my producer, Bill, and I talk about on the three-hour drive back from Springfield to Chicago, because we just saw a long prison sentence end. It's impossible to sit through these hearings and not think about what decision you would make.
在 48 年监禁后，亨利·迪将获得自由。整个过程不到一小时。在委员会今天审议的七个案件中，这是唯一一个获释的案例，我无法停止思考。在我从斯普林菲尔德回芝加哥的三个小时车程里，我和我的制片人比尔都在谈论这件事，因为我们刚目睹了一个长期的刑期结束。参加这些听证会而不去想自己会做什么决定是不可能的。
For me, there's no question-- I would have voted for release. And I want to be clear about what it means to say that, because two people were murdered, and I don't think we'll ever know what happened. I'm saying that even if Henry Dee did kill Edith and Arthur Snyder back in 1971 and lied about it all these years, even then, to me, it was time to let Henry Dee out. Past time.
对我来说，毫无疑问——我会投赞成释放票。我想明确说明这意味着什么，因为有两人被谋杀，我认为我们永远不会知道发生了什么。我的意思是，即使亨利·迪在 1971 年确实杀了伊迪丝和亚瑟·斯奈德并谎报了这么多年，即便那样，对我来说，也是时候放亨利·迪出去了。早该放了。
We spent a long time trying to get in touch with the family of Edith and Arthur Snyder. I did eventually reach their daughter. She's now about 80 years old. She told me she strongly opposed Dee's release, had written a letter to the board before this hearing and for nearly every one of his hearings over the years. She believes he's guilty. And she says, even if you're a saint in prison, if you take a life, it's forever. So you should never be let out.
我们花了很长时间试图联系伊迪丝和亚瑟·斯奈德的家人。我最终联系上了他们的女儿。她现在大约 80 岁。她告诉我她强烈反对迪的释放，在这次听证会前以及过去多年的每次听证会上都写过信给委员会。她认为他有罪。她说，即使你在狱中是圣人，如果你夺走了一条生命，那是永远的。所以永远不应该被放出来。
We talked for a while about parole, about our different views on punishment. She said, had your loved ones been killed, maybe you'd feel the same way I do. I told her that was a fair point. I still believe what I believe, but it's true. I haven't gone through what she has.
我们谈论了一会儿假释，谈论了我们对惩罚的不同看法。她说，如果你的亲人被杀，也许你的感受会和我一样。我告诉她这是一个公平的观点。我仍然相信我的信念，但那是事实。我没有经历过她所经历的一切。
I didn't say this earlier, but Illinois is one of the states that got rid of parole, way back in 1978. So only people like Henry Dee, sentenced before 1978, are still eligible for hearings like this one. So the people who come before this board are mostly in their 60s and above. They're senior citizens, which means, on any actuarial table, they pose very little risk of committing another crime. And still, the parole board only says yes to a tiny percentage-- in the 15 years before Dee's hearing, just 6% of them.
我早先没提过，但伊利诺伊州是早在 1978 年就废除假释制度的州之一。所以只有像亨利·迪这样在 1978 年前被判刑的人才有资格参加这样的听证会。所以出现在这个委员会面前的人大多在 60 岁以上。他们是老年公民，这意味着，在任何精算表中，他们再犯罪的风险都很小。尽管如此，假释委员会批准的百分比仍然很少——在迪参加听证会前的 15 年里，只有 6%。
So who makes the cut? In the numerous cases I've seen, the people who did get released, there's always a story that enough board members were able to latch onto, something that allowed them, finally, to move beyond that magnetic pull of the long-ago crime. In Henry Dee's case, it was the unbridgeable distance between the brutality of the murders and the peacefulness of his life in prison.
那么谁能通过呢？在我看过的众多案件中，那些获释的人，总有一个故事让足够多的委员能够抓住，某种东西最终让他们超越了对多年前罪行的磁吸力。在亨利·迪的案例中，那是谋杀的残暴与他狱中生活的平静之间无法逾越的距离。
Another guy I saw get paroled, he had a surgery that left him bleeding in his cell for years. The horror of his medical care in prison made his offense seem to the board almost beside the point.
我见过的另一个获得假释的人，他曾做过手术，多年来在牢房里一直流血。他在狱中医疗护理的可怕状况使他的罪行在委员会看来几乎无关紧要。
And then this other time, a man not only escaped, but lived under an alias in a different state for years. He was a beloved member of that community before he was apprehended again. The board, to my shock, saw that time when he was at large like a test case for the positive life he'd live if they gave him another chance.
还有一次，一个人不仅逃跑了，还在另一个州以化名生活了多年。在被捕之前，他一直是那个社区深受爱戴的成员。委员会，令我震惊的是，把他在逃的那段时间看作是如果给他第二次机会，他会过上积极生活的一个测试案例。
I've thought a lot about whether Illinois and the rest of the country should bring back parole, whether it makes sense to get more people in front of boards again. Parole decisions can be racially biased, completely focused on the original crime, and just random.
我经常思考伊利诺伊州和全国是否应该恢复假释制度，让更多人再次出现在委员会面前是否合理。假释决定可能带有种族偏见，完全集中在最初的罪行上，而且非常随机。
But even knowing all this, I think we need more systems of second chances. The United States locks up more people than any other country, about one in six of all the incarcerated people in the world. There are hundreds of thousands of people in prisons like Henry Dee. They've spent decades behind bars. Many will die there. They deserve another look.
但即使了解这一切，我认为我们需要更多的第二次机会系统。美国监禁的人数超过任何其他国家，约占世界所有在押人员的六分之一。监狱里有数十万像亨利·迪这样的人。他们已经在铁窗后度过了几十年。许多人将死在那里。他们值得重新审视。
When we come back, Ben tries to track down Henry Dee. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
回来后，本将尝试寻找亨利·迪。稍后，在节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Ben Austen picks up the story again.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。本·奥斯汀再次接续这个故事。
Even after sitting through Henry Dee's parole hearing, I didn't really know him. I hadn't even seen or heard him. So I tried to find out more. Here's what I learned.
即使在旁听了亨利·迪的假释听证会之后，我还是不真正了解他。我甚至没见过也没听过他。所以我试图了解更多。这是我学到的。
After Henry Dee makes parole, people at the prison celebrate, even the staff. And the day he walks out the front gate, he's getting hugs and congratulations from everyone. His mother's still alive, in her 90s. She's not walking. She can't meet him there. But Henry is ecstatic to see her.
亨利·迪获得假释后，监狱里的人们甚至工作人员都为他庆祝。在他走出前门的那天，每个人都在拥抱他并表示祝贺。他的母亲还活着，90 多岁了。她不能走路。她无法在那里迎接他。但亨利看到她非常狂喜。
He gets outside-- his first free air in 48 years-- and there are federal officers waiting for him. They handcuff him, put him in a car. Henry has no idea what's going on. He eventually learns it's for one of the attempted escapes all those decades ago. He's been granted parole by the state, but the feds are tacking on two more years. He's driven to a federal prison in Pennsylvania. His mom dies during that time.
他走出室外——这是他 48 年来第一次呼吸自由的空气——联邦官员在那里等他。他们给他戴上手铐，把他放进车里。亨利不知道发生了什么。他最终得知这是因为几十年前的某次逃跑未遂。他获得了州的假释，但联邦政府加了两年刑期。他被驱逐到宾夕法尼亚州的一所联邦监狱。在那期间，他妈妈去世了。
27 months later, the feds put him on a plane to Chicago. He's never flown before, has no idea how to board, where to sit. The flight attendants learn his story and move him to first class. He has to turn down the free drinks because he doesn't want to violate his parole.
27 个月后，联邦政府把他送上了飞往芝加哥的飞机。他从没坐过飞机，不知道怎么登机，坐在哪里。空乘人员得知了他的故事，把他移到了头等舱。他不得不拒绝免费饮料，因为他不想违反假释规定。
From O'Hare, he gets on a train. He's got directions written out on paper. He doesn't have a cell phone. He makes it to a Salvation Army on the city's West Side. That's where he sleeps. He later moves to a homeless shelter. The friend from inside who won the wrongful conviction suit who promised Henry a job and a home, it doesn't pan out.
从奥黑尔机场出来，他上了火车。他手里拿着写在纸上的路线说明。他没有手机。他到了城市西区的一家救世军收容所。那是他睡觉的地方。后来他搬到了一个无家可归者收容所。那位赢了诉讼并承诺给亨利工作和住所的狱中老友，最终没能兑现。
So Henry's trying to figure out his new surroundings, his new life, but he has medical issues. Eventually, he's admitted to the hospital. He has diabetes, fluid on his lungs. And after a few days there, he's dead. Henry Dee was incarcerated for 50 years. He lives free after his release for less than 12 months.
所以亨利试图弄清楚他的新环境、他的新生活，但他有医疗问题。最终，他被送进了医院。他有糖尿病，肺部积水。几天后，他死了。亨利·迪被监禁了 50 年。他在获释后自由地生活了不到 12 个月。
I tracked down a few people who knew Henry Dee well. I want to take these last few minutes to tell you some things about him. Henry Dee wore a frog pin around the prison. He'd leave the cell house, walk onto the yard, and dozens of stray cats would appear. He'd feed them. He was a large man, hands like catcher's mitts. When young guys asked him who his gang chief was, he'd tell them his mom.
我追踪了几个了解亨利·迪的人。我想利用最后几分钟告诉你们关于他的一些事。亨利·迪在监狱周围戴着一枚青蛙胸针。他会离开牢房，走进院子，几十只流浪猫就会出现。他会喂它们。他是个大块头，手像接球手的手套一样大。当年轻人问他谁是帮派老大时，他会告诉他们是他妈妈。
Because of his diabetes, he could get jittery or pass out on the toilet in his cell, and his friends were always on watch for him. For nine years, the person who lived with him in a six by eight foot cell was a guy named Jacob Rivera.
由于糖尿病，他会在牢房的马桶上变得焦躁或昏倒，他的朋友们总是为他守夜。九年来，那个与他在 6 英尺乘 8 英尺牢房里一起生活的人叫雅各布·里维拉。
Henry was funny, man. I would sit in a cell on lockdowns and write these letters. And not having a very good educational background, whoever I was writing to, I tried to make it seem like I was educated. And I would try to use these big words.
亨利很有趣，伙计。我在封锁期间会坐在牢房里写信。而且没有很好的教育背景，无论我写给谁，我都试图让我看起来很有学问。我会试着用那些大词。
And I told Henry-- hey, Henry, what word can I use for blah, blah, blah, blah, blah? He's like, what are you trying to say? And then I would tell him what I was trying to say, and he'll say, well, just say that. [LAUGHS] You know? And I'm like, oh, yeah. Yeah, he had a way.
我告诉亨利——嘿，亨利，我可以用什么词来代替“巴拉巴拉巴拉”？他就像，你想说什么？然后我告诉他我想表达什么，他说，好吧，直接说出来就好。[笑] 你知道？我就想，哦，是的。是的，他有他的一套方法。
Jacob called him Grandpa. A chaplain at the prison told me she called him Father Abraham because she saw him as a man of wisdom and love. Those times he came up for parole, the entire prison felt hope. Here's another man who was locked up with him, Andre Ruddock.
雅各布叫他爷爷。监狱的一位牧师告诉我，她叫他亚伯拉罕父亲，因为她视他为一个充满智慧和爱的人。他参加假释听证会的时候，整个监狱都感到希望。这是另一个和他一起被关押的人，安德烈·拉多克。
All of the guards, all of the officers, all the way up to the warden, everybody would get engaged. Like, everybody knew, Henry Dee goes to the board. He's going to the board. They might let him out, finally. This might be his year.
所有的看守，所有的警官，一直到典狱长，每个人都会参与进来。每个人都知道，亨利·迪去听证会了。他要去听证会了。他们可能最终会放他出去。这可能是他的一年。
When Henry Dee finally got released, Andre was already out. And when he learned that Henry was sleeping in a homeless shelter, he was furious. So Andre raced over to the shelter, called some people, and they got Henry Dee an apartment. They recorded a video of him seeing it for the first time. Here he is, Henry Dee.
当亨利·迪最终获释时，安德烈已经出狱了。当他得知亨利睡在无家可归者收容所时，他非常愤怒。所以安德烈赶到收容所，给一些人打电话，他们给亨利·迪弄了一间公寓。他们录了一段他第一次看到它的视频。这是他，亨利·迪。
That's your living room, all right?
那是你的客厅，对吗？
Yeah, that's my living room.
是的，那是我的客厅。
This is your little kitchen area.
这是你的小厨房区域。
Ooh, Lord.
哦，主啊。
You got a brand-new bathroom.
你有一个全新的浴室。
A brand-new bathroom! Wow.
全新的浴室！哇。
This is nice.
这很好。
Look at it.
看看它。
Well, this is wonderful. This is more room than I done had in the last century.
嗯，这太美妙了。这比我过去一个世纪拥有的空间还要多。
Henry has a full white beard. He's wearing a wool hat and a gray hoodie. And he uses a walker as he enters the remodeled kitchen. There are granite countertops. Everything is bright and freshly painted. Henry is jubilant. They all are.
亨利长着浓密的白胡子。他戴着羊毛帽，穿着灰色连帽衫。当他走进改造过的厨房时，他拄着助行器。有花岗岩台面。一切都很明亮且刚刚粉刷过。亨利欣喜若狂。他们都是。
Come look at your bathroom.
来看看你的浴室。
Man, I see it all from right here.
伙计，我从这儿就能看见全部。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I've been living in a bathroom smaller than this all my life. Whew, look at that.
我一辈子都住在比这小的浴室里。噢，看看那个。
Hopefully, you'll enjoy your space.
希望你能享受你的空间。
Oh, I do. I enjoy it already.
哦，我享受。我已经很享受了。
Nice.
很好。
You've done a wonderful job. Thank you so much. What's your name?
你做得太棒了。非常感谢。你叫什么名字？
Henry had 351 days of freedom. I saw a video of him from one of those days. He's surrounded by three little dogs leaping all over him, and he's giddy. He loved to play the lottery. And he had this new makeshift family-- the people who knew him in prison who now just wanted to be around him.
亨利有 351 天的自由。我看过他其中一天的视频。他被三只围着他跳来跳去的小狗包围着，他非常兴奋。他喜欢买彩票。他有了这个临时的家庭——那些在狱中了解他的人，现在只想和他在一起。
But he never slept in the new apartment. At night, he'd go back to the homeless shelter. For five decades, he'd been surrounded by hundreds of people. He was terrified of being alone. Andre told me that in prison, Henry was a giant.
但他从没在那个新公寓里睡觉。晚上，他会回到无家可归者收容所。在过去的五十年里，他一直被几百人包围着。他害怕独自一人。安德烈告诉我，在狱中，亨利是个巨人。
After all that, after all that he survived, he was a powerhouse. This is what we all knew. Henry Dee was so big. And he talk about his hands big. He had this deep, powerful voice. This was the character.
在经历了这一切，在所有这些他生存下来之后，他是个能量中心。这是我们都知道的。亨利·迪太伟大了。他谈论他的大手。他有一种深沉、有力的声音。这就是这个角色。
But then he came home, and the real world shrunk him. It shrunk him and then defeated him. And he never got a chance to do anything that he really wanted to do. And one of the things he told me when he was in the hospital, that he wanted to go to the observation deck on Willis Tower.
但他回家了，真实世界缩减了他。它缩减了他，然后击败了他。他从来没机会做任何他真正想做的事。在他住院时他告诉我的一件事，就是他想去威利斯大厦的观景台。
The Willis Tower, also known as the Sears Tower, is Chicago's tallest building.
威利斯大厦，也就是西尔斯大厦，是芝加哥最高的建筑。
I told him that's the first thing we're going to do when you get out of the hospital. I'm going to take you up there. But since he died, he obviously couldn't. So I took his picture that you have, that obituary. I took it up to the observation deck and took a picture of it. [CRYING] Like, yeah, Henry Dee, you made it. We got you up here, so. [CLEARS THROAT]
我告诉他那是你出院后我们做的第一件事。我要带你上去。但因为他死了，他显然不能去了。所以我拿着你有的那张照片，那个讣告。我把它带到观景台拍了张照片。[哭泣] 是的，亨利·迪，你成功了。我们把你带到这儿了，所以。[清嗓子]
As far as I can tell, Henry Dee out of prison was the same person Virginia Martinez saw in prison, the same person prison officials had been describing to the parole board for decades.
据我所知，出狱后的亨利·迪和马丁内斯在监狱里看到的是同一个人，是监狱官员几十年来一直向假释委员会描述的同一个人。
Ben Austen. He wrote a book about the parole system and the odysseys of two men trying to go free. It's called Correction.
本·奥斯汀。他写了一本关于假释制度和两个试图获得自由的人的奥德赛的书。书名叫《纠正》。
He also hosts a new podcast called The Parole Room, which centers around a different case than the one you just heard-- a kind of famous case in Chicago, actually-- with lots of twists and turns, including a guy on parole who gets out and then insists on attending parole hearings with Ben. You can find all eight episodes right now at audible.com/parole. This story was produced and edited by our senior editor, David Kestenbaum.
他还主持了一个名为《假释室》的新播客，内容集中在一个与你刚才听到的完全不同的案件上——实际上是芝加哥一个很有名的案子——有很多转折和起伏，包括一个获释后坚持和本一起参加假释听证会的假释者。你现在可以在 audible.com/parole 找到所有八集。这个故事是由我们的高级编辑大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆制作和编辑的。
["PAROLE SONG" BY SLAUGHTER BEACH, DOG]
["假释之歌" - SLAUGHTER BEACH, DOG]
Our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show include Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德制作。今天节目组成员包括肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、亨利·拉尔森、塞思·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·纳尔逊、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Today's show was fact-checked by Christopher Swetala. He's the person on staff who first heard Ben's podcast and thought we might collaborate on a story with him. Fact-checking help from Heena Srivastava and Rudy Lee.
今天节目的事实核查员是克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。他是最早听到本的播客并想到我们可以和他合作一个故事的工作人员。事实核查帮助来自希娜·斯里瓦斯塔瓦和鲁迪·李。
In the years since his 2019 hearing that you just heard, one of the board members, Sal Diaz, has died. Special thanks today to Ben's producer, Bill Healy, to The Invisible Institute, who funded some of the early reporting that Ben and Bill did on this, to Sayre Quevedo, Lori Wilbert, Jason Sew Hoy, Josh Crist, Marciane Tanada, Lauren Olsen, Jelly Monteros, Ashley Lusk, and Jake Shapiro.
在他 2019 年听证会后的几年里，委员之一萨尔·迪亚兹去世了。今天特别感谢本的制片人比尔·希利，感谢资助了本和比尔早期部分报道的“隐形研究所”，感谢塞尔·奎韦多、洛丽·威尔伯特、杰森·苏豪伊、乔什·克里斯特、马尔西亚娜·塔纳达、劳伦·奥尔森、杰莉·蒙特罗斯、阿什利·拉斯克和杰克·夏皮罗。
Thanks also to all of our Life Partners-- that is, everybody who has signed up for the new premium subscription version of our show, which you heard me mention at the top of the episode. You can join them-- join us-- as our partner in keeping the show strong at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
感谢我们所有的生活伙伴——也就是说，所有签署了我们节目的新高级订阅版本的人，我已经在节目开始时提到了。你可以加入他们——加入我们——成为我们保持节目强劲的伙伴，网址是 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He actually screen tested, back in the day, for the little girl character in ET, the Drew Barrymore part. But the scene where they opened the closet and see ET and scream? Torey just could not deliver. They call action. He looks at ET and blurts out--
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他年轻时确实试镜过《外星人 ET》里的小女孩角色，德鲁·巴里摩尔的部分。但在那个打开衣柜看到 ET 然后尖叫的场景中？托里就是演不出来。他们喊 action。他看着 ET 脱口而出——
I liked the guy. He's impressed me. But he needs to go home.
我挺喜欢这个家伙的。他给我留下了深刻印象。但他需要回家。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
["PAROLE SONG" BY SLAUGHTER BEACH, DOG]
["假释之歌" - SLAUGHTER BEACH, DOG]